by taking just a few small details into
account you can build a fluid and
natural feeling first person camera in
3.js without too much work that you can
use in your games and other projects
i think my first experience with first
person camera games as a kid was playing
stuff like duke nukem 3d quake that kind
of stuff
that was ages ago at this point but the
genre is still alive and well today with
examples like overwatch apex legends and
well doom again but like the new one
anyway the concept is reasonably simple
instead of kind of creepily following a
character around like you're in a drone
or something
you can imagine first person cameras as
being more from the point of view of the
character so imagine the camera is
actually just wedged right into their
face or maybe even more accurately since
most of the time you seem to be able to
see hands and guns and stuff the camera
is sticking right through their chest
that's a bit more accurate as for
building one well it turns out that 3.js
already has one see this terrain
tutorial here this uses the 3.js first
person camera controls wherever i point
the mouse it looks in that direction
eventually
and i can move around using the wasd
keys or i guess the whatever you want to
call them the doom keys so ws brings you
forwards and backwards and a and d let
you strafe side to side we can peek at
the source code for this thing and see
that it's pretty easy to set up there's
just a few lines of code that's involved
and that's about it so here i've already
set up a basic skeleton of a scene using
the same code as my physics tutorial
probably because it was the last thing i
worked on
and at the top here i've imported the
firstpersoncontrols.js file after that i
just need to instantiate an instance of
the controls in the initialization code
here i create the first person controls
set a couple parameters and we're good
to go so this works i mean that
shouldn't be too much of a surprise this
comes with 3.js but the problem is that
well
it'll need some work i mean it does the
job just fine if you just want to add
some quick first person controls to a
project but if you want to use this for
a game it's definitely going to need a
lot more polish
so of course we'll build one from
scratch because that's often my answer
to things so first thing we need to do
is capture input specifically we need to
intercept both the keyboard and the
mouse input i'm building out this class
here call it whatever you want i'm
calling this an input controller and in
the initialize function we just need to
accomplish a few key things
we want to declare the current input
from both the mouse and the keyboard and
then we want to attach to event
listeners for both the mouse and the
keyboard events the reason that we're
storing this in current input is because
you can't just pull the current state of
the mouse and keyboard each frame when
you're doing your camera logic at least
not in the browser so as the mouse has
moved and the keys are pressed we stash
the current state of the mouse and
keyboard in the class and that lets us
query for the mouse and keyboard state
later awesome eh the next step is
implementing the actual first person
camera itself so i'll start by declaring
this first person camera class and that
really only needs one parameter the
actual 3.js camera that is kind of
puppeting
down in the scene initialization for the
app we'll instantiate our first person
camera and pass it the e3.js camera we
also need to make sure that in the step
function we call the update function so
the camera can actually perform all of
its logic
in the constructor we need a couple
things
we need the input obviously otherwise we
can't react to mouse and keyboard events
so i've declared an input controller and
we've got some miscellaneous member
variables like rotation and translation
of the camera which i've represented by
a quaternion and a vector 3. so now the
first thing we need to do is actually
look in the direction that we want to
look in and for a first person camera
this isn't super complex what this
amounts to is figuring out how far the
mouse has moved relative to the last
frame
so in the input class i've already taken
care of this by adding the mouse x delta
and mouse y delta and whenever the mouse
moves we just compute the delta by
subtracting the current mouse position
from the previous frame's mouse position
super simple stuff and by having this
all in one class we can track snapshots
of the state of the mouse and keyboard
for the current and previous frame in a
simple and easy way so back to the
camera since we know how far the mouse
has moved this frame we can convert the
x and y movement into spherical
coordinates so basically turning those
into v and theta coordinates
at this point we need to convert those
into a rotation
and there's no single way to do this you
can do it however you want you can use a
matrix 4 you can use the 3.js object 3d
api doesn't matter do whatever you want
what i chose to do was to construct a
rotation around the y-axis and another
one around the x-axis and the final
rotation is just those two rotations
multiplied together now we create this
update camera call which just copies our
rotation into the 3.js rotation
easy peasy we've got a functioning
camera now i can move the mouse around
and look in the same direction so this
is definitely on the right track but we
can't move around yet so let's implement
that i'm adding this update translation
function to the camera class and the
first thing we need to do is check what
keys are pressed
since i'm using the wasd keys i'll check
ws for forwards backwards and sd for
left right strafing
now we need to know which way is forward
so we use the fee rotation to build a
quaternion and since opengl is a
right-handed coordinate system 0 0
negative 1 is the default forward
we transform that by our rotation and we
have the forward direction for wherever
we're facing yay
left is basically the same deal but you
use negative one zero zero
then all that's left is actually copying
this into the camera's position and
we're golden
and here you have it we can look around
we can move but it's all kind of weirdly
smooth and unnatural like you're on a
camera dolly track
so let's add a bit of camera movement
the standard go-to move is to add a bit
of head bobbing using a sine wave so
we'll do that an easy way to do this is
to accumulate a value whenever you're
moving so in this case we're checking if
there's been any movement and then
storing that in head bob active
then when you're updating the camera you
can just add a small offset to the y
position using a sine wave
and we'll just multiply that by some
hard-coded constants to make it a bit
faster
there we go head bobbing i can move
around and we bob up and down and
obviously if i stop walking i don't keep
bobbing up and down
i guess you could add some breathing or
something but i'm not going to bother
one thing to notice though is that when
i move forward let's use a way bigger
bob effect to show this
notice that when i move forward whenever
i let go of the keyboard it stops at
whatever height in the wave function i
happen to be at and that seems wrong so
what i'm doing here is we're basically
going to compute how many steps we've
taken by taking the timer multiplying by
the frequency
turning that into an integer and that
way that'll allow us to stop at the end
of a step instead of mid-step there you
go now you kind of move forward but it
finishes the step instead of awkwardly
stopping in the middle one more thing
that's kind of annoying me here when you
as a person walk obviously your head
goes up and down as you move but you do
compensate a bit naturally by keeping
your focus point fixed
you don't just bob your vision randomly
up and down as you're taking steps
but here we do
it's a bit easier to visualize it now
that i've added this little aiming
reticule thing
you can see that what we focus on goes
up and down with the head bobbing and
personally i find it super annoying
so let's add a little bit of nuance here
what i've done is stored all the objects
in the scene in an array called
this.objects
and i'm just looping through and casting
array forward from our camera
you could totally use ammo.js or
whatever physics library you want but
let's keep things simple here and not
involve any extra libraries for now
the overall goal here is just to figure
out what you're looking at
so what we're doing is we'll take
whatever you're staring at and modify
the camera's final rotation a bit just a
tiny little bit and force it to look at
the intersection point and we can do
this super easy since we kept our own
rotation and position separate from the
3.js camera
and once you do that you'll notice that
the movement is just a tiny bit smoother
there's still the head bobbing movement
going on but it kind of comes off a bit
more natural since your focus point
remains intact let's kill off the silly
bounce that i have going on add a tiny
bit of camera smoothing some nicer
textures and some post effects that i
lifted from garrett johnson
check his github out and it's starting
to look pretty cool
it's not finished but hopefully this
gets you at least thinking about these
tiny little flourishes and subtle
details that can really impact the final
look and feel
code's all up on github go nuts
until next time cheers